hey I'm Cody Simpson and one of my
favorite movies of all time is lords of
dogtown lords of dogtown was based on a
true story of three guys Jay Adams
States prata and Tony Alva who
revolutionized the world of
skateboarding i think when i first
watched the film at like 13 14 i watched
it just because I thought it was super
cool and I thought the guys were cool
and I thought they did cool tricks and
stuff and also Heath Ledger's in it was
like my final and now I see the deeper
meaning behind I see that the moralistic
sort of aspects i see that the lessons
in bulk is going through something
similar I think the one character that I
wrote two more than the others would be
Jay Adams just because as the success
started becoming a factor he didn't buy
into a lot of the things that the other
people buy into and that's sort of you
know where I'm at in my head with my
music right now just my life because I
got so scared that my initial passion
for playing the guitar and stuff was
being sort of sold out in like a
commercial way when i first got into the
music business i was super young it's
signed originally when i was on my 13th
birthday so you know being super young
and impressionable you want to make
other people happy especially you know
successful executive adults and then you
get to a certain age is so the same age
that you know someone like Jay Adams got
to and then kind of realizing that you
didn't have to that you can you do it on
your own and just live your life the way
you want to kind of open it up more than
I thought I would I think my jump going
independent and you know trust in my
inner spirit has led me to a place where
I feel like I can inspire other people
do the same thing being like you can do
whatever you
Martha T can be whoever you want to be
you don't have to listen or conform to
other peoples like you know ideologies I
think it's all about developing your own
sort of philosophy on life I'm Cody
Simpson and I love news
you